this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking what about your
mind all day when it's complaining and
it's yelling at people and it doesn't
like stuff but if you're attracting that
way so you eventually catch on that it
is not about getting what you want it is
about learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and they tell
you not to do it you're always capable
of that because you're the one who's
doing it hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I quit I'm a business partner I
struggled to keep going I was making 300
bucks a month and felt like a complete
failure and the thing that saved me that
pulled me up was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs I got the
motivation from them I also got the
strategies of what to do next so that I
can go off and achieve my dreams and
quite honestly I still need the stories
today myself to continue my motivation
to take it to the next level so today
let's learn some powerful manifestation
techniques to create wealth enjoy
inside you are the one who's closing
your heart you close it you are the one
who's closing your mind you do that
they're your thoughts it's your feelings
there's nobody else's so you are in
there doing these things so if I tell
you the way to stay open is to not close
I don't teach how to stay open that's
more like finding out how to get what
you want I'm interested in you learning
to not close but a difference if I say
to you I want you to open your heart
right now you wouldn't even know how to
start
but if I say to you somebody says and
you don't like don't close you know
where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only last a minute I'm going
to see a beautiful sunset you feel like
oh my God I looked into the face of God
then you go right back into your mind
with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want the teeth the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it technique number
two is change the unconscious program
with Bruce Lipton what do you do on a
daily basis Bruce are there any routines
any practices that you do to keep
yourself
in this happy contented creative mode
I wake up in love
I just wake up in love the rest of the
day flows so beautifully there's no
practices anymore for myself why I put
those programs in they run automatically
I don't have to even practice it because
practicing means I don't have the
program and I want to make the program
but if you already have the program then
you don't have to do the practice and
all of a sudden you just naturally wake
up you're in love you naturally are
helping your partner your community your
friends you're just it's natural so it's
not like let me work on this let me let
me be you know let me be more loving to
my partner it's like I don't have to be
more loving to my partner we're already
fully in love
it's like you know people say I love you
know I love you more so I say no I
always tell my wife uh how much love
full amount it's like the gas tank how
much love oh I'm filled up with love you
can't put any more love in there it's
already filled up it's already there and
so practice by definition means
something's not working and you want to
engage yourself to make it work and then
you do a practice but what if you did
the programming already you know when I
got with my partner Margaret uh I still
had programs for my parents that weren't
any good but she knew about programming
I know about programming and this is the
important part because if a couple
doesn't know about programming then when
some Behavior shows up unexpectedly it's
like oh who are you what's this all
about uh but if you already know that
programs exist and a bad program comes
up it doesn't go into an argument it can
go into a discussion do you want to have
this program and then I would say what
programmer oh you didn't see what you
just said or did it's like oh and I said
well let's change the program and then
we change the program so what do you do
over a period of time you edit these
programs and when it gets to the point
of it's editing then do I have to
practice more or anything I go no I
changed these programs already if I
here's a simple point I said the
conscious mind is wishes and desires the
subconscious minus program yes what if
you took your wishes and desires and put
them in as programs then the answer is
what whether you're conscious or whether
you're subconscious you're still going
to the same destination yeah and now
that's the secret part it's not a
lifelong struggle once the programs are
set you don't have to work on it anymore
it's already done so it's not like I got
to do this every day I go no once you if
it's a program you will automatically do
it every day without even thinking
you're doing it have you got any final
words final thoughts
final bits of advice to share with
people to help
I guess improve the way that they feel
well yeah it's just basically simply
this is that we are creators we came
here to create but if you've been
programmed then you're not creating the
program is creating and the idea is if
you can then use your creation to put
the program in that you want then you
can manifest what you want in this life
that's basically what it is and uh
and the idea is what is it we're really
looking for you know as I said a lot of
people give me the money give me the
money I go the money you think is going
to make you happy and I'm going to say
look there are a lot of rich people of
the unhappiest people I've ever seen in
my life and so it's not that but we've
been some kind of programmed the
competition get this you'll have this
you're going to be better and some of
the poorest people are some of the
happiest people I've ever seen uh and
then all of a sudden it starts to
realize then happiness is not a physical
thing I need to get things to be happy
technique number three is surrender with
Gabby Bernstein whenever you're in that
space where you're feeling like I need
that thing
instead of needing that thing to feel
good why don't you offer up what you can
give
it's a lesson I learned 17 years ago
when I first got clean and sober in the
12 steps of Alcoholics Anonymous
yes
how do we serve how do we show up how do
we be for others if you want to attract
more into your life give more of what
you want to receive
be in the service of others
in a way that is
natural to you in a way that is
Meaningful to you and the way that is
joyful to you
in a way that you are able to
some people can can can cut a check for
something somebody can show up and be of
service some people can just literally
hand someone a banana on the street
sometimes it's just lending an ear
oftentimes when you are in your own
story in your own drama the best thing
you could do is pick up the phone and
see how somebody else is doing
because when we take the focus and the
intention off of what's not working with
us and we start saying how can I be of
service to you we get back into
vibration with the universe
the universe is an ever-present energy
of Love within us and around us
supporting us and guiding us and that
energy is meant to be in the service of
our presence and the presence of all
those around us
and we have to show up for that we have
to hold that we have to commit to that
whatever it is that you're doing in your
life whether it's being a partner to a
person or being a parent to a child or
being a teacher or being a boss or being
a whatever you are in your life or many
of those hats in one I want you to ask
yourself
how may I serve
how may I serve more maybe you think you
are serving how may I serve more
really getting humbled
and asking a higher power of our own
understanding how would you use me
how would you use me
where would you have me go what would
you have me do what would you have me
say
and to whom
my favorite prayer from A Course in
Miracles where would you have me go what
would you have me do what would you have
me say and to whom
and when we open up to that service and
we expand our heart and we start to give
more of what we want to receive that's
when the universe starts to truly just
get in sync with our energy and it's
really a Act of surrender service is an
act of surrender
because if you're in the service of
somebody else you don't have time to be
thinking about your own drama
you don't have time to be frustrated or
annoyed because you're now in the
service of others even if it's just
energetic service now this means showing
up with a good attitude
being a little bit more High vibe in the
nail salon service to others
it's helpful it has a ripple effect
throughout our day and this is a form of
surrender and I talk all the time about
surrender when we surrender our desires
to the care of the universe the universe
will always reflect them back to us
and so I I want to encourage you to
think of an area of your life where
you're clutching and you're holding on
so so tightly do you know that area
anyone
how does that feel
not so good no no
what
stuck yeah stuck it's not a good feeling
to be stuck in the energy of holding on
and grasping and controlling something
that's something we want really badly
and so I'm going to ask you tonight to
offer it up
to give it over
to ask the universe to reveal signs to
you that you're on the right track
every time in my life when I made that
commitment and I've asked for that
guidance that guidance has come back to
me tenfold I remember when I was about
six books in I don't know I guess I was
35 or something at 36 years old at that
point and I was out on this major book
Tour all over Europe and I was writing
the next book while I was on the plane
to this book and I was really burning
out and at the time if you've read Happy
Days you know I was really struggling
with dissociated trauma I didn't know
what was actually going on and why I was
a workaholic and why I was pushing and
controlling and so I was really
suffering
and I remember I had to get to Germany
to go give a talk and then got off the
stage in Germany and I got on a plane to
London and I was the last speaker on the
stage and I just bombed like the speaker
before me that's not his fault I bombed
and then I left that stage and when I
say bomb like my energy just wasn't in
the elevated place and I got off that
stage and I got on another plane all the
way back to Canada and I'm bummed
because
I want to be of service I want to show
up at my highest capacity but my world
was crumbling from the inside out and I
just was like hand in my head and I
remember looking down and crying and I
just said Universe I need a sign that I
am being guided and supported
and I got to Canada and I rushed from
the airport back into another backstage
area and backstage and I'm sitting in
the Green Room nobody else is around
because I'm the last person to go on the
stage that night
and I'm sitting there and I feel this
energy come through me this Angelic
presence and it feels as though I have
these angel wings just coming through me
from behind and I breathe and I can just
see this presence of this angel
and I stand on the stage I step out onto
the stage and I felt this energy and
These Wings as if they were expanding
across the stage
holding me and guiding me
and it felt so elevating and I felt so
connected again
and I got on stage and I felt really
good and I started to gather my things
to get back on another plane and there
was a friend of mine's husband was in
the room with me we're the only ones
left everybody had left the building and
he sees this charm on the table
and he picks it up and he's like what's
this and he says you know Gabby I don't
know why but I think this is for you
and he hands me this charm
and it's a little angel wing and on the
back of the angel wing it says believe
and I looked at him I'm like yeah man
that's totally for me
a year later I went back to Canada to
give another talk
and I was sitting behind a table giving
a book signing and this young woman runs
up to me and she's like Gabby Gabby I
saw you talking Canada last year it was
so amazing and I just couldn't find you
at the end but I wanted you to know I
left you this charm
it's an angel wing that says believe
it's right here too bad you can't see it
an angel wing
that says believe
and so I carry this with me wherever I
go I'm going to put it back in my pocket
so I don't lose it I carry this with me
wherever I go and I
love the tremendous
Divine wisdom of the universe
and I love that we all have the capacity
to tune into the energy of service and
love and faith and joy and in the energy
of that love and service and faith and
joy anything is possible my friends
anything is possible also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there technique number four is take
action on your vision with Michael
Bernard Beckwith what can I now let go
of that no longer serves me in other
words something may have served me five
years ago yes maybe in a compulsive
Behavior maybe a defense mechanism it
may have been a conversations that I was
in habits been on survey today
what can I let go of that no longer
serves me it's not a guilt-inducing
exercise it's just an awareness yes
then from there we go into willingness
we wrap our attention around being
willing because where there's
willingness there's a way if there's
will fullness there's a wall you create
a vibrational wall
so I bring people into a state of
anything you try new you had to be
willing yes even if you didn't know how
to do it yeah but you were willing to do
it yes so willingness is power
so I combine willingness with vision
what must I become yes what can I what
do I already have what can I let go of
we become willing and then the universe
takes over
and you start to dream it you start to
have um moments of
something's telling me to go left why
should I go left I don't know why I
should go tuition you follow you end up
meeting the person you were supposed to
meet
that you didn't even know if you had
gone right you wouldn't have met her or
him
things just start to work out because
you're in the flow of your vision
so it's transformational it's not just I
want the car yes you know because
sometimes people want the car nothing
wrong with getting the car but after a
couple of months you know the car's old
you know
you really want you want inner
transformation and the car yeah
100 I always say to people you you don't
actually want the million dollars what
you want is what the million dollars
does for you absolutely it's the the
freedom that you feel the enlightened
moment that you did it that you feel
happy and elevated so you're seeking
answers to what your soul is calling out
for and now you're free to actually live
the life that you're ordained to live to
give the gifts to share your yes being
yes and and and then the more you give
the more you have the more you give of
yourself like the more you teach the
more you know
because as you start teaching you start
to learn while you're teaching you start
learning new different ways of saying it
nuances you start getting more new
information the teacher learns more than
the student
because you're in the flow of giving the
information so as you're living this
life as a giver as a individual that's
sharing gifts the hands of the givers
are never empty
it's only the hands of those who are
stingy and trying to hold on and hoard
that end up losing so true so we're
we're in the process of teaching people
how to catch a vision yeah how to be
their real self and then share it
be in the world give up yourself totally
and completely and then watch as you
will attract everything that you need to
keep going to the next level of your
life technique number five is create a
vision board with Jack Canfield I know
you're a huge believer in vision boards
and seeing it into existence and you
started your very first vision board in
1970s I've seen your your travel vision
board I've heard you say you have a
vision board at the back of your door
before you leave your you know your
house and you actually look at it in
your face it's right in the back of this
office every time I leave this office
there's a whole Florida ceiling Door
full of all the images and things I want
to achieve that I haven't achieved yet
yes so was that a practice you created
or did someone teach you that
someone taught me that I don't quite
remember who
um it started with just surround
yourself with images of what you want uh
some people have what they call Vision
books uh where it's like a three ring
binder with those plastic insert Pages
you just put pictures you can flip
through your book uh I find if I put
them in a book like that I kind of
forget to do it but if it's on the door
or the refrigerator I've had them on my
refrigerator doors I've had them on my
bathroom mirrors I've had them on a cork
board in one place I lived so it really
depends on you know where you are and
what you're doing sometimes I put a
single image like when I one point I
bloomed up to 230 pounds I want to get
down to 195. so I took a picture of a
very
muscular guy out of a muscle the
weightlifting magazine cut out my head
put it on it that was on my bathroom
mirror for a year and I got down to 195.
so sometimes it's very targeted uh my
favorite story is about a woman named
Cynthia Donna who is a student I do a
free workshop at the community college
every year for the local Santa Barbara
community and I taught that to the group
she went home and made one and I often
showed in my workshop it has pictures of
Greek the Greek Islands you know those
white buildings in Santorini with the
blue blue sea behind it and uh it had a
creek cookbook it had a said love
relationship and married and things like
that because she wanted to be married at
the time she did not have a boyfriend
she'd never been to Greece and less than
two years later I have a picture of them
in Santorini sitting on one of those
white building walls with the blue
background and a wedding dress on a
tuxedo and um so it it just works but
you have to do it and most people don't
do it that's the thing it sounds so
bizarre or so weird or so strange but
basically the universe responds to your
dominant thoughts and the feelings you
have related to those thoughts so if you
can surround yourself with pictures
for example when I wanted a certain car
I went down to the dealership I sat
inside the car I rolled the window down
I put my head out the window I had the
dealer take a picture of me with this
brand new Lexus and within a year I
owned that Lexus and so it's it's just a
matter of believing it's possible
technique number six is reprogram your
subconscious mind with Marissa Pier
first of all the mind can only work in
the present tense many will go next year
I'm going to have a bikini body next
year I'm going to be so wealthy next
year I'm going to have love next year
I'm going to be happy and you see the
mind doesn't know what next year is in
the same way that when you say to a
child we go doing that tomorrow they go
is it tomorrow today is it yesterday
today because they can't future pays the
Mind actually isn't great at Future
pacing you have to say now I am becoming
super successful now I'm joyously happy
now I'm attracting the most amazing
wonderful lasting love now right now and
if you add the words now and right now
to the things that you want your mind
understands oh you want this I better
action this whereas next year five years
from now I'm going to be happy your mind
doesn't really know what that means the
mind works in the present tense only
it's why people who are depressed can't
imagine getting better it's why when
you're in pain it's very hard to imagine
no pain because the mind works in the
present tense secondly the mind only
responds to words that make pictures and
the more clear and Vivid and detailed
the better if you say well I'm never
going to eat cake again I'm just not
ever going to eat cake I'm not
interested in cake cake doesn't thrill
me what you're saying is I am interested
in cake and cake Thrills me and I need
to eat cake again because the words no
not don't
don't work saying to your kid don't
touch that vars they hear touch the
lodge I got a such a weird kid every
time I say don't touch that they touch
it that's because the mind doesn't hear
the word don't doesn't understand the
word don't and does not act on the word
Stone have you done a New Year's Eve
resolution never eat chocolate again how
long did that last probably days often
not long at all so you cannot prefix
with don't not never because it doesn't
work and thirdly the word you use must
be exciting dramatic powerful and super
descriptive here is a rule of the Mind
the way you feel about anything at any
time is down to two things the pictures
you make in your head and the words you
say to yourself we all make pictures and
words successful people make powerful
pictures and exciting words and people
who are not successful make negative
pictures and negative words I'm going to
get sick now because Winter's come it's
flu season I'm gonna get sick because I
ate that food and I don't think the
waiter's hands are very clean I'm gonna
get tired because I've been up all night
the neighbor's dog was barking people
who succeed say I've got a fantastic
rock hard Constitution I can sleep
through anything so the situation
doesn't change they both sleep with a
barking dog
they both eat in the same as and one has
a belief
this is great and the other has I
believe this will make me sick
so you have to use very very exciting
those people say to me you know I'm I'm
meditating and I I say things like every
day in every way life is getting better
and better that is a completely useless
waste of your time try to picture that
every day in every way my life is
getting better rather is that Vivid is
that descriptive is that exciting is
that detailed as that set your mind on
fire with passion and Direction no of
course it doesn't now say something else
I have a skill and a passion and drive
and determination I am going towards my
dream career like a magnet like a laser
I'm scared I'm gifted or I'm a lovable
person I'm lovable and warm and amazing
and I'm finding who I want and they are
finding me
that makes a picture whereas
I'm looking for love that doesn't really
make a picture so the wording is so
important you must use Dynamic words
descriptive words and even the words you
put in front of words they're saying I
am motivated and passionate and driven
is an amazing word saying my body is a
wellness producing machine or saying my
body is a freaking awesome
Wellness producing machine makes a very
different picture to I'm trying not to
get ill I'm hoping not to get depressed
I I'm I'm trying not to get fat no you
say I have a phenomenal extraordinary
super efficient fantastic metabolic rate
and my body Burns off whatever I eat I
eat good stuff healthy stuff and if I
eat it gave me not so good doesn't
matter my brilliant body my phenomenal
metabolic rate use everything I eat to
build a perfect body for me and I have a
phenomenal incredible metabolism here's
another one that will help I have an
extraordinary foolproof Dependable
memory your mind because I know what
that means extraordinary foolproof
dependable
those words make such a clear image of
what you want and even better you say to
your mind you know what mind what I want
what I insist on what I require of
myself every day is a foolproof
incredible awesome phenomenal Dependable
memory now try doing this I I don't want
to forget things anymore I mustn't
forget I must remember I mustn't forget
I must remember you can see that that
doesn't work turn your mind on set your
mind on fire with words reprogram your
subconscious mind for Success remember
it has a job and its job is to do what
you tell it your job is to tell it
exciting things understanding
the prerequisite I must speak in the
present tense only I must add in the
words now right now I must use really
exciting words that are descriptive and
make a clear picture so my mind knows
and even the words I put in front of
words
they work absolutely they work do this
for yourself do this for your friends
especially do this with your children
not oh well you can't read you are a
phenomenal reader your brilliant brain
understands the words it understands the
sense and technique number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is believe with Rhonda Byrne most
people understand the rule of Attraction
as you positively think about something
and I say this with you know inverted
comments
they believe that it's you know you
think about something and it happens
there is so much more to it what are the
reasons why the Law of Attraction
wouldn't work for somebody what are they
missing because they have a belief that
is contrary to what they're asking for
so so let's say that they're visualizing
that they want
I don't know a new car or a better car
or something like that but also they've
had they've got a belief that
um I don't deserve I don't deserve
things you have to work hard and really
struggle to get anything in your life
you have to work hard and struggle for
money I don't have the money all of
those beliefs will prevent the new car
from manifesting
and so and so and so
what I would like to say to everybody
is that you deserve everything that you
could possibly want you deserve to live
the life that you want to live it
doesn't matter where you started out it
doesn't matter what family you were born
into there's no such thing as born on
the wrong side of the tracks or there's
no such thing you can you can be do and
have whatever you want all you need to
do is think about what you want and not
contradict it with what you don't want
so for example if you do have a beliefs
I don't deserve this or you have to work
really hard and struggle for money which
is basically Global beliefs yeah then
I'm telling you let it go don't believe
that anymore because it isn't true it's
not true you deserve everything you are
all the power that exists you don't
think you are you think you're this
little tiny dot in the universe you're
actually holding the universe in your
hands you know you are you are
everything you are infinite intelligence
you are the wonder of the world you are
the master of the world you're the
master of your life and so now you can
start living that way and just keep
telling yourself that and understanding
that and maybe reading the secret or
anything else watching everything
listening to everything that you do
because it's really easy to change a
belief like we put beliefs inside of us
by Bill just by believing something that
somebody says and very often a lot of
the beliefs came when we were children
and and we just kind of swallowed it all
but when you say the opposite of I
deserve everything that I could possibly
want and I am all the power that there
is and I can have whatever I want to be
do or have and you will say that often
you will override those beliefs
because a belief is just a thought you
keep thinking
first of all every time we have a
thought we make a chemical and and if
you have uh an unlimited thought you
will feel unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits that signal another part
of the brain to release peptides or
chemical Messengers that signal hormonal
centers and when we get that arousal
from the thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
turns out that the emotions that are
created from the thoughts are the
signaling mechanisms of the body
thoughts of the language of the brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words a person wakes up
in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems and those problems
are memories that are etched in the
brain that are connected to certain
people certain objects certain things at
certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right now
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems now you feel
unhappy now you feel anxious now you
feel fear so the moment we feel those
emotions it takes a thought and a
Feeling
a memory or an image an emotion a
stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person's fabricating by thought
alone the body's believing it's in that
environmental condition
so if the environment signals the Gene
and that's the truth and the end product
of an experiences in the environment is
an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is the brain
checks in with the body and says yeah
you're feeling pretty miserable you're
suffering and we tend to generate more
thoughts equal to the feeling that we
have
and so then we get caught in this Loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think greater than how we feel our
feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
right and so we call that the familiar
past and then a person gets going in the
day and they start thinking oh I gotta
see this person I got to go to that
meeting I hate doing this and now they
get in their routine and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is The Sweet Spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted of energy because it's
believing that it's living in an
emergency situation and an emergency you
tap all the body's resources for some
threat whether it's real or imagined and
so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool but the arousal that's
created from those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion and in a sense
they become addicted to the life they
don't even like and this is why change
is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to
be a victim I'm not going to talk trash
about anybody I'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just gonna stop
today so now the body which has been
conditioned emotionally to be the Mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that come on this is
a good time to suffer it's your ex's
fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh you know it's
the weather what the news whatever it is
and if we accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy than step
into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choices you did day before and here's
the payoff
you got to stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95
percent of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking are slipping by their
awareness unnoticed because they're
hardwired in their brain because they've
been saying I can't it's too hard my
life will never change in someone else's
fault those thoughts have consequences
in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice how they're
feeling and they're no longer the
program they're the Consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
they're they're when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and you're tweeting
and your Instagraming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling
but I now know that if you take a person
and you say Okay close your eyes sit in
the in the Silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay I'm gonna
feed you you can check your cell phone
you can shower you can have your coffee
but when I say
and so then Here Comes The Challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in The Familiar
few familiar past or predictable future
you're not going to think about how long
you've been meditating what you got to
do you you labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say I
think I'm meditating wrong I always say
oh no no you're doing it right because
when you notice that your body wants to
get up and check your cell phone or have
a cup of coffee and you become aware
that it's on autopilot and wants to do
that and you say uh come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
the third of mine now we've researched
this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because David
is fighting Goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner the later the body is trained to
a new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life and
they're they're working and lowering the
volume to that emotion the more they
lower the volume of that emotion the
more they're going to take their
attention off that person and problem
and they're going to take their power
back there's going to be a break and
their attention from that circumstance
and now they build their own field and
now there's energy to heal now there's
energy to create a new life now there's
energy for the mystical moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
I think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming overcoming overcoming
overcoming until we become somebody else
and when that occurs and the person
starts thinking differently and they
start acting differently and they start
feeling differently their new
personality and yeah they they start
seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities now
Crossing that River of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire and wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention I was 19 years
old okay when I had a mentor a man who
was in his 50s very very successful he
agreed to to Mentor me and to teach me
what he knew and so he sent me home with
some paper
and on the paper it said
what do you want to achieve in your
health
relationships what do you want to
achieve financially what do you want to
achieve charity what do you want to
achieve as far as experiences when do
you want to retire by how much money do
you want to make how he asked me about
10 pages of questions
and at 19
I I had no idea how much do I want to
make I want to make enough to pay my
bills I want to make enough to you know
just eat well and then have some fun I
want to go drinking with my friends I
want to go party and travel a little bit
and pay for my apartment and a nice car
and things like that but he had me think
you know one year
five years 25 years when I was 19 and he
made me write down
the answers to these questions even
though they weren't I had no idea how to
achieve them he made me write it down it
took me a whole weekend
and I went back and he looked at my
papers and so he looked at health and
wealth and relationships and career and
business and he goes good way to do the
exercise I'm very proud of you he says
now I want you to increase that amount
and so I said that you know by the time
I was 45 I was 19. I said by the time I
was 45
I was going to be a millionaire
nobody in my family
was a millionaire not my aunts not my
uncles not my cousins nobody in the area
that we lived in and I wrote that down
and he said no that's not enough he says
you can do better than that and I'm like
I'm swallowing I'm scared I'm afraid how
am I going to become more than that how
can I have all of this he says don't
worry about the how right now
you worry only and not even worry but
you write down what you want
[Music]
and so I went back home
and started to write again a game and
and took another you know half a day to
to redo my goals
and he said to me great now in order for
you to achieve those goals what do you
have to believe
wow I said well I have to believe that I
can I have to believe that I deserve it
and even though I didn't believe that I
deserved it he said well would you think
you had to believe I have to believe
that it could be done I have to believe
that I could learn the skills I would
have to believe so he made me write out
what I would have to believe good
question and then he said great what do
you think you would have to do every day
wow amazing question
um well I guess I would have to come to
work every day and I'd have to really
get good at what I'm doing and I'd have
to learn more that I'm learning right
now because I hated to learn back then
and I'd have to you know gain more
skills which I didn't have any the only
thing I was good at was I had an easy
time talking to people like I am with
you now and he said great well let's
make a list of all of these things and
let's come up with a plan
to do this is it's every day let's look
at some beliefs
and so every day he would have me look
at my goals
and I would sit in my chair
and I'd have my goals you know that he
had me right and I would take my fingers
which he told me to touch my goals so
that I would send a message to my brain
as I was reading it and seeing it to
reinforce the goals that I wrote then I
would read
the beliefs
that I needed to have
I have all the intelligence I need to
achieve these goals
I can now acquire all the skills to
achieve these goals and I read about 20
or 30 different beliefs every day and
for the first month or two months while
I was reading all of this
in my head
this one word
kept coming up you know what the word
was
because as I would read it my brain
would say
that's not true and he told me that my
brain would try to talk to me and tell
me it's not true and he said if you keep
doing it over and over and over again
your brain's going to get tired of
telling you it's not true and especially
if after you do this you take some
actions to upgrade your knowledge
upgrade your skills you'll develop more
confidence and more certainty
so he taught me how to use the telephone
to make telephone calls to people
to see if they were interested in buying
a real estate property or selling their
home I was in real estate at 19.
and you know for the first month it was
hard second month it was hard the third
month it was hard but as I got better
and more comfortable at being on the
telephone talking to people that I
didn't know that I thought didn't want
to hear from you or talk to me
I found one person then two people then
three people then five people who said
yes
because as I became more comfortable as
I became more skilled as I gained more
knowledge
people received me differently
and in my first year I made thirty
thousand dollars I was 19.
which was five thousand dollars more
than my father made as a taxi driver wow
then he started to upgrade my skills a
little bit more
and he started to teach me some very
specific
things to do in real estate and in my
second year at 20 I made a hundred and
fifty one thousand dollars wow five
times more income because every day for
one hour
one hour a day I practiced
my beliefs I practiced seeing my vision
I rehearsed it I got on the phone I
upgraded my knowledge I upgraded my
skills I love your story thank you and
and so he kept he kept directing me a
little bit at a time to become more
tomorrow than I am today
and he said to me something that changed
my life
it says if you invest one hour a day
on your personal growth and changing who
you believe you are
that is the equivalent of nine
40 hour weeks
of effort
one hour day for a year is nine 40 hour
weeks if you and I said today we're
gonna learn break dancing we're going to
learn knitting and we're going to spend
nine weeks 40 hours a week
we would get good at what painting we
would get good at at knitting we would
get good at darts we would get good at
playing a musical instrument if we were
committed to one hour a day
so I've practiced one hour a day for 32
years
and that one hour a day
has changed my life see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone there
isn't anyone that cannot live the way
they want to live
see
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want and then they
back away or they go to move and they
don't they go to change jobs and they
don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting x-tape
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left
Field above boom in comes a y-type idea
what is a y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
yet might be moved to another city
change jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some for some strange
reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved if they're going to
act on that idea they don't understand
what's going to happen but clearly
understand this your central nervous
system is the most complex electrical
system in the universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling yet would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an XY vibration it's not in
the X vibration not the one that we're
comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable
no on a conscious level everything's
going crazy on a conscious level we
experience doubt that doubt turns into
an emotion called fear and that fear is
expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going Beyond
where you're at going to a new level I'm
going to tell you something when I set a
goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
I lived there for the first 26 years of
my life and for the last 50 I've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up
there you go to emotionally involved in
the Y idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
they're experiencing some crazy stuff
they start to doubt their ability he'll
never be able to pay for it they
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and dang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
that's energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they gave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek when you have a goal
in your head it's not even a goal it's a
fantasy it's a dream when you have a
book like this you can call it your goal
book and you write out your goals and
you go through I'm just about to take
you through bit by bit stage by stage
you go back to that but you can look at
it you can touch it you can just make it
real so remember if you do not write out
your goals as a plan and write out how
to accomplish them you didn't have a
goal you have a wish you have a dream
you have a Daydream if you want to go
get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do on your phone too you
can make a document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's why I could go
hang on a minute hey I got ten dollars
here there you go you go well that's not
my goal but you said I want more money
and I learned this almost to work with
women who were infertile that come and
go you know I just want to be pregnant I
want to be pregnant so bad if I was just
pregnant I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever I'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and respect
each other and you can have a health
goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many ways as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why to leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
and I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich I long to be in a loving
relationship write it as if it's already
happening I am a millionaire I am in a
loving relation do you Michael that
doesn't make sense it does make sense
because your mind only works in the
present tense when you say next year
I'll have a bikini body it doesn't know
what next year is
and so you must write your rules in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal my goal is to be a
millionaire my goal is to be famous my
goal is to be wildly in love and I think
that's it
it's not it if you want to be madly in
love writer all the reasons why but then
you have got to put yourself in front of
the kind of person you want to share
your life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you wouldn't I don't think so
you know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12
years that's a long night 12 years and
people said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get a lot of
money for KFC I said yeah but it's not
my goal and he stuck it out and many
people have got so close to success and
had to keep going and you have to keep
going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
whenever I get an idea I have to do
something immediately trust your ideas
believe that they're amazing and and
manifest them into the world I love it
I'm not taking it from the approach of I
want this book to be a New York Times
bestseller and I'm sitting there
visualizing my book being a New York
Times bestseller I'm not visualizing
myself being on Brendan burchard's stage
in Puerto Rico to a couple thousand
people uh that's not the process I
typically go through although I'm open
to that maybe being a mistake I don't
know it's never really felt like
it's worth it I don't know I'm sitting
there I've done it many times sitting
there visualizing I've never really felt
like that made a difference I'm open to
being totally wrong but
oh I do apply it and it's massively seen
an impact is as soon as I get an idea
for something it's it's go time trust
that Vision that came to you trusted
idea it's in your head and do something
immediately about it when I thought
about the idea of having a house of
building a custom home I then went off
and built the 5 000 square foot custom
home like inside of the year we had the
whole thing done when I thought about
silly things like I thought about having
a mannequin I was watching Green Arrow
on TV and I loved how they all had their
their mannequins when they were in their
their layer or their realm they had
their outfits their costumes on a
mannequin and I thought I feel like I'm
I'm the Green Arrow I'm I got the Deep
Hood look I could be this is this is the
believe Arrow right uh I want a
mannequin too and then inside of a week
I had my own mannequin here and so it
may seem crazy main sea wild but that's
how I tend to operate and I think it's
amazing right now I'm thinking about
doing a 30 day a challenge on my YouTube
channel my main YouTube channel where
every day for the next 30 days I have a
series of videos to help you build a
better life so like 30 days to a better
life and it's going to be some of our
best work and I thought of the idea and
now immediately we're doing it and so
trust in the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them and I
guess manifesting them to the world I am
a thousand percent all in on
the sitting and visualizing the thing
that I want I have a struggle with and
I'm open to making it better and and
being changed we're faced the hardest
time with this is my health so I broke
my neck last year right I wore this for
for uh 60 days taking it off for 10
minutes a day that was it and I had a
concussion and I had two spots in my
neck that were broken and I did some
meditation with a guy named Michael
Edwards who led me through this guided
meditation and he helped me and he was
doing it with me in person uh over over
the phone sending me videos and first
off was getting the concussion away
because I'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation account really
helped the concussion the second part
was the visualization so I have a bone
in the back of my neck that broke off
so the big bone broke and is healed the
little bone just kind of broke off like
the tip like imagine I guess the
fingernail kind of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together and
and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because it's not a big
deal don't worry about it
and Michael was convinced that I could
heal myself and I could make that bone
come back together and so every uh night
and every morning I would do it twice a
day meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and and you know it
takes some you know hand sanitizer or
not hand sanitizer take some lotion and
and you know put it on my neck and just
as I'm to get more tactical like as I'm
doing it the the bones connecting I
talked to John Assaraf who was a another
you know legendary expert in his field
and he's he's fully convinced that it
can come back together through
visualization through meditation I
haven't done it yet I haven't I haven't
I haven't cracked a code on how to do it
I wish I did we did x-rays UH 60 days
later and it's still just as
disconnected it's still just it didn't
move a centimeter a millimeter closer
and that was honestly a little bit
uh you know negative or low or defeating
and and my motivation to do it as
intensely has has waned I haven't been
doing it twice a day every day I still
want to believe that is possible and I
still
kind of believe that it's possible and
maybe that's not enough maybe that's the
problem uh maybe the problem was I never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen so I would I
would love for that to work I would love
for meditation to work I've meditated
with I don't know how many different
people so many different people I've
never really felt the benefit
um of having a meditation just feels
like I'm like I'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just I don't feel extra
Clarity or anything coming out of the
meditation so
I believe that has worked for other
people I believe that it can work for me
I haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where I'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why I still feature people on my channel
because I'm trying to learn through the
process as well but but the idea of
taking the ideas that do come to you and
taking immediate action on them right
the last letters of of law of attraction
is action doing something trusting them
I think a thousand percent that can
serve you it has served me I know for
sure can serve you to learn to trust
your ideas and do something immediately
today about it and then build momentum
towards it and that big crazy thing you
have in your mind may not even be that
big and crazy once you actually start
taking some action on it and so that
part I'm a thousand percent down on and
you need to do something today in your
life to change
and the other side I'm totally open to
feedback suggestions on how I can get
better how you can get better
[Music]
oh I I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn how to manifest some money
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there everybody at
least kind of in the mass Market what
you're trained to think about when you
think about manifesting is vision boards
and when you hear the word vision boards
you think about the big stuff